and we are live what is of the leaf
nation happy Thursday I missed you guys
last week I had my son he didn't have
school so we spent a good chunk of time
together and didn't have I didn't make
the time to come and see you guys as I
was with him but I'm excited to be back
I'm trying to make this commitment every
Thursday to be with you here either for
an AMA or just having a guest on just to
be able to provide content for you but
also get some interaction going I have a
new webcam I don't know if you guys
notice I look I'm looking looks a little
different looks kind of orange e to me
I'm using this Brio 4k webcam from
Logitech this is the very first video
that I've ever done on it it's a lot
more widescreen you can see more of my
space I have to figure out the whole
orangie thing maybe change the color
oh no okay that I'm gonna leave that
alone
if the techies out there watching have
suggestions for how I can fix my camera
settings what you think is wrong with it
it looks a little off to me let me know
but we're doing a AMA today so I'm
excited to be here guys leave a question
in the comments and let's see how many
we can get through in the time that we
have first up is going to be Chris Chris
Scott is questioning before we even
started I love that the early bird named
Chris gets the worm Oh guys also if you
tag me it's a lot easier for me to see
it Chris what are your thoughts in
communication to spread one's brand
awareness so this is an interesting
question because I don't know how else
to do it like you need communication to
spread your brand awareness I don't know
how else you're gonna spread your brand
awareness so it's figuring out what
you're saying for right like figure out
what your one word is figure out what
your mission is and then you have to use
communications to spread it I just see
every every impression of your brain
whether it's social media which is the
that could be the logo doesn't have to
be you as an individual but it could be
the logo social media whether it's your
customers talking about you what there's
advertising to me that's all
communications so it's essential it goes
but I feel like I'm missing a part of
the question and if you want to follow
up I want to be able to make sure they
give you more value next what do we got
give me questions if you give me a tag
it's gonna be easier to see hey Evan
what books do you recommend well there's
two fantastic books right here that I
highly recommend I was actually just
looking at the data the sales data
before getting on and we had a fantastic
December for one word it like had this
big spike up in December a bunch of
people buying it as Christmas presents
so thank you for that apart from that my
favorite books the the go-to ones for me
one was the 4-hour workweek
mostly because it taught me about
delegating and it taught me about
managing my time not about working four
hours a week and Tim Ferriss doesn't
work four hours a week either but that
idea of you don't have to do everything
yourself and you need to put a high
priority on the time that you're
spending is really important so I think
that's that's recommended reading and
then the other book that had a really
big impact on me was what's it called
radicals and visionaries Satya swaro
I don't think it's imprinted anymore and
it basically profile the different
famous entrepreneur each in each chapter
and it's kind of like what my top ten
rules is you know when I was when I was
getting started my business I wanted
just kind of daily inspiration and ideas
I didn't want to read a huge chunk of a
book every single day but I wanted a
quick hit of something that would
inspire me and also give me some ideas
on how I could be a better entrepreneur
and so that was what that book did and
I'm continuing a tradition with mine
with the top ten was a success that's
what I got
what else you gene Evan what to do when
motivation doesn't work so what I leaned
in on is one the goals that you have
need to be motivating in themselves you
know I don't really get off by the
motivational videos and I think whatever
works for you you need to go out and do
for me watching somebody yelling and
screaming and like rah rah doesn't get
me going but I
no people and friends of mine and like
they can't they can't get up without
that that in their life so great if it
works for you fantastic for me it's much
more about having an important mission
as a starting point like feeling like
the work you're doing is important gets
you excited at least it does for me I'm
sitting here in my office by myself
nobody's here and I'm talking to
hundreds of people this is gonna be
viewed thousands of times and I want to
be here for you like I want to answer
your questions it gets me excited to
know that at eleven o'clock Eastern I'm
coming on to do an AMA with you guys and
all day long today I have interviews
with different people lined up and I'm
just gonna be by myself here in the
office but I'm excited and motivated to
do it and so I think I don't think
there's such a thing as just lazy people
I think people just don't have goals
that inspire them and so making sure
first of all that you have something
that inspires you that the work you're
doing is inspiring you can only force
yourself to do something that you don't
like for so long before you quit it's
just it like before you just give up on
it before you give up on unbe neck
cellent at it and that's what most
people do i think most people are stuck
in a dead-end job that they hate and
they're just doing enough so that they
don't get fired but they're not really
putting everything they've got into it
and they don't look forward to going
into work and and work in there and you
just don't have a motivating goal for
yourself where when you have a goal and
a vision that means something to you
then you're much more likely to do the
work and you you've already had these
moments all of us have had these moments
you've had moments where you felt
inspired and unstoppable and bold and
confident you've already felt that why
what led to that it's because you had
some motivating goal that was inspiring
you you want to go off and do it and so
I think that is a starting point to then
it's creating an environment and routine
that supports you
I like the wide-angle now because you
can see my office a little bit more you
know these people inspire me my morning
routine inspires me the habits that I
have on a daily basis inspires me and a
lot of it is automatic
right like I set up my office once and I
come in every day and all these people
you may know some of them you may not
know well you definitely don't know all
of them they mean me nothing to you but
I mean something to me I like walking in
and I see these faces and it means
something to me and I don't have to
think about it I don't want to think
about motivation I wake up I come in
here and I get motivated I read a page
from my book the top 10 was a success
right I made that for myself because I
read that every single morning and I get
two ideas from a genius entrepreneur and
the more I'm around that the more makes
me more bold and confident and strong
and I feel unstoppable and so it's
figuring out for yourself what the
physical environment looks like and what
your morning habits or routines look
like so that you can be motivated every
single day
so that it's not relying on somebody
yelling at you or watching a one
specific video over and over and over
again and hoping you're gonna get the
same result so that's what I think
next play mods how do I find my passion
I think it's something that you discover
I think I think it starts with
self-awareness I think it starts with
figuring out what you stand for right
figuring of what your one word is what
your most important core value is but
then it's how do I apply that so I'm
about believe but how do I apply that I
love helping entrepreneurs how did I
find that by going out and trying to be
an entrepreneur I don't think you're
gonna find your passion by looking at a
magazine and sitting on your couch and
just thinking about it
it's like thinking your way into a
relationship right like you could have
the perfect picture for the person you
think that you want to marry but yeah
that's probably not gonna be the person
you marry and you don't know until you
get out and you start dating and so what
I would do is encourage you to follow
the things that get you excited as soon
as you get an idea I think this is
really important as soon as you get an
idea for something you have an idea for
something that you want to do and maybe
some huge idea or maybe just some go
hiking for the weekend idea as soon as
you get an idea for something they'll
find some small way to get started
and then just see if you like it so for
example maybe your idea is you want to
start a YouTube channel great go out
this weekend and start it and try it and
recognize that it's going to suck you
will be terrible on camera and you won't
know how to use the gear even this is my
first time using this camera I'm not
happy with the setup I'm gonna find a
way to fix it but I keep going and you
test it and just see how it made you
feel don't be so concerned about the
outcome don't be so concerned about the
final product if you're making a video
for your YouTube channel being great did
you enjoy the process if you are
thinking about skateboarding you know go
out and get on the skateboard and try
and you're gonna fall and failing you're
not gonna be able to do any tricks right
if you can just stay on the skateboard
you've won so not being so attached to
the outcome and the result but being
attached to the process did you enjoy
did you enjoy making the videos do you
enjoy getting on the skateboard because
much more important than having some big
goal that like I want to hit a million
subscribers or I want to hit ten million
subscribers or whatever it is more than
me hitting ten that 10 million
subscribers on this channel is mean join
the process like I like being here with
you guys right now it's crazy that we've
got hundreds of people watching I'm just
sitting here in Toronto and I'm able to
provide value and help you guys out with
your business I love that the day that I
say man I gotta make youtube videos I
got to do another stupid ama I hate this
the data that's my mentality I'm out I'm
I quit I'm gonna move on and do
something else I think that's really
important and I think too many people
get stuck in the wrong path or something
they get stuck in something that they
really liked before and then they lose
their passion and they keep doing it for
the next decade stop it move on to
something else
and so finding this finding the things
that inspire you and then going out and
doing something about it
take one small step don't make it be
perfect don't worry about the outcome
just do you want to go back like the
criteria after going on a first date
with somebody is do you want to have a
second date with them did I enjoy their
company not am I going to marry
this person have babies with them right
now right there's too much pressure so
you go on the first date and then do I
want to go on a second date and a third
date do you want to spend more time with
this person do I want to get to know
them better
it's that same approach you get an idea
you're not gonna make a million dollars
from it right away in fact you're gonna
make zero you're gonna spend a ton of
energy and time and not get any results
that doesn't matter do you enjoy the
process because if you enjoy the process
and you want to come back and do it
another day that's how you discover the
thing that you love and when you get
finally good enough at that thing then
you'll be able to make money from it so
that's how you find your passion
next shake music Evan how could I
combine entrepreneurship and humor for
my new channel I think this is an
amazing idea I am NOT the most humorous
person my son might think I'm funny and
maybe my wife and maybe a few other
people but I don't do a great job of
injecting humor into my channel and I
think there's a white space for it I
think comedy is a great way to be able
to teach important lessons I think the
best comedians we profiled a ton of them
on this channel lots of different
comedians they're great storytellers and
the best stories have some kind of
message and you can get people to think
and get people to change and get people
inspired not just by yelling at them but
also through comedy through telling a
funny story right and so that's what I
would really try to do I'd be looking at
okay what are the lessons that you want
to teach in entrepreneurship so the
finding your passion as an example just
that last question how do I find my
passion how do you tell that story give
a great answer and make people think but
in a funny way right so I I went super
practical here are the steps boom boom
boom
you could just as easily get people to
think the same thing by telling a funny
story and maybe even move them even
further than I did by telling a funny
story and so I think it just starts with
the lesson that you want to get out and
then telling a story around it and I
would it be examining all the comedians
that you look up to and love and look at
the message behind the comedy that
they're sharing because the
comedians always have a message and make
you walk away not just saying I had a
great time but making you think and
reflect on your life for something
that's happening in the world so that's
what the great storytellers do the great
comedians do and I want to see you bring
that down your inertia man I'll
subscribe to that channel I want to see
it bring it okay what else we got
questions questions you Ulysses do you
set daily goals so in the micro yes I do
so what I normally do is I have a
schedule so that Monday is one day twos
is one another date Wednesday's another
day so tres Thursday filming this
Thursday is my public-facing day
Thursday is when I do hangouts
interviews Skype calls radio shows
YouTube interviews all that kind of
stuff and so I'm starting off with you
guys I'm gonna do something for Peter
Hollens his channel later on right after
this and then a bunch of Skype
interviews hangouts the day is
jam-packed full of interviews I know
that's happening on Thursday but I don't
know exactly what's happening each
Thursday right sometimes you do a name a
sometimes I have a guest on sometimes
I'm doing Skype calls and what have you
so it's a it's a rigid system of what
happens on a Thursday but the day will
structure and flow a little differently
each time I like starting the day with
an intention each time so one of the
things that I do I got this from Mel
Robbins I take a sticky pad no you can't
see it come on camera focus can't really
see it anyway
I take a sticky note I got my own custom
sticky note so you haven't come I could
will leave sticky notes I get inspired
every morning looking at my logo and I
write three things down so it says
Thursday goals at the top and then goal
one goal to goal three and then it says
hashtag believe and then I sign my name
and then I stick it to the back of my
phone so that multiple times during the
day I'm seeing what I want to get
accomplished that day and these are just
more reminders it's not I need to get
this done and this done and this done
but so for example number one is give
the best interviews of my life so when
I'm on with Peter Hollens after this I
want I want that to be the best thing of
you've ever given it's just a mindset
you know I want to get into that mindset
going into it and so I'll come up with
three intentions for the
I think it's more like that it's more
intentions for the day than goals
because the micro goals I already have
like I'm gonna do the Nate I'm gonna do
an AMA great I don't I don't need to
write that down and check it off like
it's gonna happen anyway so I said three
intentions for the day and I just like
getting into that headspace it's part of
my morning routine that sets me up for
success what else we got
you got a question tag me up Jackie hi
Evan how did you get ready for a
breakthrough so every major breakthrough
that I've had has come from crushing a
limiting personal belief the first one
that I think of is it from a business
context is I was 19 I had my software
company I was selling biotech software I
wasn't a science person I wasn't a
computer person I was selling with
people two three times my age who had
PhDs and I just felt that was too young
like my my thought process was I'm too
young I don't have a science degree I'm
not from a big company they're not gonna
take me seriously they're not gonna
listen to me
and so that really held me back and so I
would hide behind email and hide behind
the website and hide behind the product
and never make personal contact with
people unless it was written over email
and eventually I realized they don't
care how old I am all they care about is
kind of help them and I had a product
that could help them and once I started
getting in front of that then we started
seeing some results with the business
and so every every time that I made a
breakthrough it's really what I find
helpful is look at yourself in the
mirror and ask yourself this look at
yourself in the mirror and ask yourself
this question why am I not more
successful and that's a tough question
but when it comes back the answer it has
to be something that you take
accountability for and when you do then
you start to grow then you start to have
more success because if the answer to
why are we not more successful is
because of your parents or the school
system or the president or any of those
things
then you're never gonna be more
successful because it's always somebody
else's fault where when you take the
accountability and say no this is my
fault I'm here because of me
and I can fix this right then you can
change because I can fix this because
you have the ability to go off and do
something about the situation where as
long as it's the president's fault or
your parents fault nothing's gonna
change and it feels great to complain
and great to blame them because you
don't want to take accountability feels
amazing but then you never grow and so
if I were to ask that question before
I'd be like well because I'm too young
well because I don't have a science
degree well because I'm not from an
established company and just breaking
the mindset to say I'm gonna change that
you know I'm not too young it doesn't
matter from that from an established
company it doesn't matter if I don't
have a PhD in biotechnology
I have something that's valuable and I
believe in and as soon as I made that
switch then we sort of seen success and
realize it was just a story I was
telling myself and so that's how I
prepare myself for a breakthrough each
time next nor I Oh should I quit school
I have a detailed business plan many
adults think it's a good plan I have a
great idea that can only be achieved in
a time school Occupy's I'm 13 that's a
tough one I don't have a fantastic
answer for you because I'm honestly on
the fence with it I think school is a
great if you want to be an entrepreneur
I think school is a great back-up plan I
think if you ever wanted to get a job at
any point in time it's gonna be really
hard if you're 13 and don't even have a
high school degree there's gonna be
really really hard to get a job and
maybe you're okay with that maybe that's
fine maybe like yeah I never want a job
ever to make that decision now at 13 for
the rest of your life I think it's hard
if you ask me five years ago what I
would I have a huge youtube audience and
would you
to be my thing I'd say no my god no way
and if you ask me in five years where
I'm gonna be like I have no idea and so
I think it's dangerous to set one path
and assume that that's what it's gonna
be for you and and not have options if I
if I were you and I was thirteen I would
stay in school and try to figure it away
now maybe I'm more risk adverse maybe I
like having some options on my plate I
would figure out a way to do both and I
did when I was in university I used my
university as a way to help my business
I designed the course with the professor
to basically tailor everything around
using my company every time we had a
project in school and marketing class or
whatever class I always use my business
as an example to get research done on
different things I was working on my
company I could always use my University
as a way in to get the research done
because it was for school projects it
allowed me to open up a lot of doors you
can call on alumni of the school to get
advice for your business plan I think
there's a lot of ways to do both so in
my view I think it's just dangerous to
cut up options too soon I think it's
great to be able to embrace the and try
to do both at the same time other
entrepreneurs will disagree and say you
know what school is stupid and it's a
huge waste of money I don't I don't
regret the time I spent in school and I
also don't feel like I learned the time
in university especially from education
perspective that really set me up for
any kind of success so that's what I got
next Corey how do I grow my youtube
channel
Corey make better content and be
consistent that's it and being
consistent leads to making better
content in terms of like specific hacks
and cheats and shortcuts ten-minute
content plus wins and so I'd be looking
at how do I get a plan together so I can
ten minute daily content and when I say
that people freak out like how do I get
to ten minutes a day it's crazy I'm
making one video a week and it's four
minutes long you don't do it right now
but that's the goal that's the plan and
when I say one video a day at 10 minutes
that's the light version right I want
you at 2 videos a day I'm at 3 videos a
day it works and the second it stops
working then I'll stop doing it but
right now with YouTube's algorithm
multiple videos per day 10 minutes plus
that's good quality it's not just you
sucking on camera for 10 minutes you
don't extend it just for the sake of
extending it but that will help you win
and that's it
like in every market it's making better
stuff your service your product has to
get better you have to commit more to it
you have to practice more at it you want
a better YouTube channel get on camera
more practice more put in the reps right
put in the reps go back on my channel my
first video was nine years ago I can't
believe it's that long if you asked me I
would have said like six or seven but I
looked at it yesterday for a reason I
forget and it was nine years ago and I
sucked on camera and how did I get to
here and how did I pass people who I
consider have way more natural talent I
mean five thousand videos and most of
them sucked and most of them went
nowhere but I made five thousand videos
and in that process I got better right
you practice anything you're gonna get
better at it you practice skateboarding
you're gonna get better at skateboarding
you're not gonna fall every time you get
on it
it's just that's how you learn and so
that's what you need to do on YouTube
channel practice more take it more
seriously take it more seriously this is
what you're committed to being excellent
at now start applying yourself and get
to the point you're making daily
10-minute content and then go twice
daily that's what you should do next is
they know all right Dana with a question
I know you had entrepreneurial
tendencies when you were young do you
any of that in Hayden or his interest
very different than yours whew that's a
great question
Hayden first of all is very artistic so
here's and he's right here he loves art
he loves creating so we are both super
creative people he expresses it through
visual art and through drama like
traditional arts so he loves acting and
he loves memorizing music and lines from
movies and he loves drawing I hated all
of that stuff we draw together pretty
much every time I'm with him but I do it
for him like I he's almost a better job
than I am so that's super interesting to
see where that goes he's also a lot more
outgoing than than I am I'm an introvert
I know it doesn't come across in his
videos but I'm super introverted I don't
talk to people out in public generally I
don't say hi he's very social so we'll
see where it leads
I haven't forced him into
entrepreneurship he knows he knows what
I do he likes being on videos every now
and then I don't know if he'll be an
entrepreneur and I don't care it's
really just embracing what he loves
doing and right now it's all in on art
and helping him get as far as he wants
to go and that and if that becomes an
entrepreneurial path I think everybody
needs a little bit more entrepreneurship
even if you have a job I think I think
artists need to be entrepreneurs I think
managers need to be entrepreneurs and so
that thinking I think will really help
but really the path with parenting at
least my perspective on parenting is
much more figure out what they want to
do and help them do that instead of you
forcing your path it's it's the reason
why I have my parents and in me on the
wall behind me there is because my
parents allowed the three of us who have
two sisters to do everything that we
wanted to do and we all took very
different paths from each other and from
my parents my parents had a much more
you know safe stable traditional path
and all three kids went off on totally
different directions I'm probably the
safest of the three siblings to be
honest and so I want to continue that
tradition down to my children Chris what
are your thoughts on the habit rule 8020
I think it's honestly much more like 95
5 to be honest I think most of the
activities that you do will come from
sorry most of the results that you do
will come from a super small set of
inputs I think that you just have to
keep testing and exploring I think
looking at this YouTube channel as an
example a lot of the results a lot of
the subscriptions a lot of the views
come from a select handful of videos
compared to the most of the videos that
I put up at the same time though I want
to continue to experiment and test and
find new paths and create new kinds of
videos and most of them won't work out
like most of your experiments will not
work out most of the things that you try
will fail and the most successful people
in the world the people behind me on the
wall and people that you look up to they
failed their way the success and that's
fine it's it's the 5% of things that
work that lead to 95% of your results
but you can't really predict it going in
and so you try and so I'm a big believer
in it I think it's just much more skewed
than 8020 deep ion is saying what is
your way of pushing through really hard
times one is to expect really hard times
you know as an entrepreneur you're
you're eating glass every day like
that's part of the game you you need to
I don't want to say necessarily enjoy it
but maybe enjoy the challenge of it I
think I think hard times are definitely
gonna happen to you in life but
especially as an entrepreneur if you
don't want hard times don't be an
entrepreneur there's a lot of great
times that come with it too but if you
don't enjoy pushing through hard times
and you're gonna have a really hard time
being an entrepreneur you'll quit when
it gets high
and that's when you need to buckle down
and be a leader and get back on the
horse and keep going I have a strange
thing about me and that I welcome the
hardness I was talking to Lily
yesterday from the unlocking Lily series
and we're talking about the common
advice on on dieting is throw away all
the junk food in the house right like if
you wanted if you want to diet and stick
to your diet throw away all the junk
food in the house you're not tempted you
know throw away that bag of Doritos for
me if I'm on a diet
I want the Doritos bag like right here
juice is a reinforcement that I'm
awesome and I'm not gonna eat that bag
you know I don't know it's that it's I
want the bag in front of me
because I know I'm not gonna eat it
because I'm not strong because I believe
in myself that much I use the Dorito bag
as motivation to stick on the diet
so maybe I'm weird I don't think most
people do that but that's that's kind of
like embracing a struggle welcoming the
pain not seeking it out that's it that's
a different thing
I think people seek out drama just for
jamas sake but I'm okay with the pain
what gets you through it is remembering
the why what you're trying to do like
why are you suffering through this pain
well I'm trying to help a billion
entrepreneurs I want to solve the
world's biggest problem that's inspiring
to me why are you suffering through the
pain that you're suffering through and
if there's no reason then then quit like
if you can't figure out a reason then
why do you keep going and doing what
you're doing
stop go do something else and then the
other thing that really helped me is
looking at all the stories that I have
covered I love doing a few guys but it's
selfishly for me is why I do it because
I like surrounding myself with success
and seeing how all of these people that
we profiled struggled and struggled and
struggled and struggled and struggled
makes me feel like I can do this too you
know a lot of the people that I profiled
you already have more resources you
think you don't have resources you
already have more resources and most of
them had when they started it's crazy
and so that perspective helps me looking
not at how somebody makes an extra
million dollars now but their story of
how they started I'm realizing they had
a worst story than me they had less
resources and I do they had more pain
like whatever pain you're dealing with
now they dealt with more pain they made
it through that inspires me and you know
once that I'm gonna give you a third one
the third one that helps me that I
remind myself of is this is just a
warm-up whatever pain and challenge
you're suffering right now I tell myself
this is just a warm-up because I want to
be capable of solving bigger problems
and handling bigger pain and that if I
make this pain that's in front of me my
threshold that this is all I can handle
it means I can't handle more I can't
handle a bigger problem
I can't tackle a bigger challenge and I
don't like that I want to be able to
tackle bigger problems I want to be able
to solve bigger challenges and so I
remind myself that this is just a
warm-up that I am capable of more it's
probably what the Doritos bag is too
like this is nothing I got this right
this isn't the kid stick to a diet the
diet is not a big problem it's not a big
challenge it's done it's easy right it's
just a warm-up
I'm keep a little doing way more and so
I try to remind myself of that and that
that always gets me motivated too
that's what I got okay what else
vivianne will it be okay to read 52
books a year and start a YouTube channel
on book reviews any idea can work the
key is you need to be able to provide
value just because you've read 52 books
and you've done a video on it doesn't
mean that that video is gonna be any
good right and except that your first
videos probably won't be very good
that's okay do you love it do you enjoy
the process and do you want to learn how
to get better at it
book reviews are great category on
YouTube there's lots of people who do
book reviews there's
lots of people who have had success
doing it most people don't have success
doing it like every other industry most
people don't have success doing it the
ones who do genuinely love it here's the
thing if you're doing it because you
just see an opportunity stop you're
gonna lose because the people who love
doing book reviews will destroy you if
you're doing it because you love the
idea of doing book reviews on a regular
basis and you love it because you want
to inspire people and you want to make
it easy for people to get those concepts
in the book and distill that information
to them great
then go for it and try it that's gonna
be your path and you may start it and
say you know what that was okay but I
don't like it
great quit immediately and move on to
something else so it doesn't matter what
I think of the idea because all of these
that all these ideas can work it's
figuring out do you enjoy the process of
creating that video creating that
product creating that content and then
are you willing to put in the time
effort hustle commitment to making it
better so that you can actually start
providing value to your audience
next ash Ashutosh Ashutosh what to do
when you have all the resources but you
don't want to work but you know this is
what that makes your life what to do
when you have all the resources but you
don't want to work but you know this is
what makes your life if you don't want
to work you're in the wrong thing period
go find the thing that you want to do
and at the start it may be some inkling
ages some be maybe some tiny idea great
go explore that tiny idea because you
can have success in any field like book
reviews is a huge industry I couldn't do
it
I don't read enough books and I don't
enjoy the process of breaking down a
book to make a video of it what I do it
once or twice maybe could I do that
every week no way I just don't enjoy
doing it but it doesn't mean that it's
not an opportunity for somebody else so
you have to find the thing that you love
doing and that you want to work for
because you've had those moments
again like I was talking about before
you've had moments of I can't wait to go
off and do this thing so find a way to
do that more and find a way to turn it
into a business model and sometimes at
the beginning doesn't make any sense at
all from a business perspective quite
often it doesn't make sense from a
business perspective when I started
helping entrepreneurs I never thought I
would make money never cuz entrepreneurs
don't have money how am I ever gonna
make money doing this I did my first
seminar to help entrepreneurs in in
Toronto and three people showed up to a
free thing after tons of promotion right
like three people show up to a free
thing how will you ever make money doing
this how ever many years ago that was it
didn't make any practical sense I just
loved it like those three people that I
talked to I loved helping them and I
knew I had to do it again I want to go
back and do it again and the more I did
it the more momentum built up the more I
got better at doing it the more value it
could provide a venture that turned into
a website eventually I turn into YouTube
eventually turn into book deals and
brand deals and in a company with a big
team but I didn't think it was gonna
make sense at the beginning and so
that's what you need to find stop trying
to make decisions with your head and
make it more with the heart if you don't
love doing the work that you're doing
you're in the wrong thing period go find
the thing that you want to do Carlos how
to deal with shapeshifters or people who
do not take personal responsibility so
it depends on the context if you are
looking at people on your team then fire
them don't work for them don't work with
them if it's at a job you know move to a
different division or move to a
different company you don't want them in
your environment you know if it's
somebody in your family that's tougher
but I'd be looking at limiting exposure
for sure you do not want to be around
the people who bring you down and who do
not have the same values that you do
that concept of you are the result of
the five people close
this to you is partly why I made my
channel to write for myself is I wanted
to be around more successful people so
everyday I'm filling my head with ideas
from Steve Jobs and Howard Schultz and
the people in the book right that's what
I surround myself with every day and so
I slowly become like them they're
pulling me up right even though I've
never met them they're pulling me up to
be bolder and more confident and chase
my dreams where if the people in your
life are pulling you down and are not
taking accountability not taking
responsibility shape-shifting telling
lies the more you're around that the
more you're gonna become like that them
and the more you're gonna not like your
life and so you need to eliminate that
as much as possible from your life and
again if it's family members maybe you
limit exposure you know I'm not saying
never talk to your mom again that's a
tough thing although some people have
done that and it's the best decision
they ever made but if it's people that
you can cut out from your life then do
it it can be really hard to grow with
somebody I think this is what makes
relationships marriage is difficult
because it's not so much who you are
right now if you want a 50-year marriage
to last and still love each other it's
not about who you are right now it's
about can you grow together in 50 years
you won't be the same people that you
were when you started
so can you grow together or if you're
both on your different paths or if
you're on a path and this person is just
staying straight back that's gonna
become this chasm that little difference
at the beginning is just gonna grow into
this big chasm this big gap that'll make
you realize why am i with this person
it's the reason why we don't stay
friends with most of our high school
friends and university friends as you
get older you just have grown into
different people and that's okay that's
fine I mean it's a little sad but it's
okay you make new friends
because you don't we you don't want to
be plain small just to please the people
around you and I think that's what a lot
of people have to do they maintain their
existing relationships and so if you
have people around you who are like that
then you have to cut them off
you have to find new friends new people
to be around people who again pull you
up to be a better version of you what do
we got shake music how do you manage
your time to achieve multiple goals so
the best way that I know how to do it is
having different different days which I
talked about earlier on so Monday I'm
doing work with the investment companies
that I've put money into right so I work
with Toronto dine-saw so I work with
Alec so we're good Lily on her business
Tuesday I'm making videos for the
YouTube channel
you know Thursdays I'm doing public
facing day I really have a hard time
switching tasks super have a hard time
I've done a lot of work to ignore
distractions so you know I have a I have
a cell phone but no cell phone number
you can't reach me like there's no phone
service I have no phone anywhere you
can't call me cuz it's a it's a it's
your agenda for my time right you can
email me and I'll get back to you on my
time right well we'll do this session on
my time right you can't call me you
can't distract me I have a hard time
switching tasks so I would have a hard
time for example like this the energy
that I bring here I'm carrying into my
interview with Peter next and then all
the interviews afterwards and I actually
get more energy as a day goes on like I
could do this all day long and the last
one would be better than the first one
but I I have a hard time going from this
and then if you ask me go write your
next book for 90 minutes and then come
back and do the interview with Peter and
then go right again I can't do it I look
like getting in the zone of that
particular day so when I'm with Alex and
Lilly I'm with them we're focusing on
that business we're trying to grow it
when I'm focused on my youtube-channel
Tuesdays I'm going through reviewing
content trying to make my strategy
happen to build the best channel for you
guys
I'm not I'm not doing anything else I'm
not being distracted and so that's what
I find works really well have different
days to do different things have a
consistent winner routine at the start
that sets you up for success but then
different days different things
experiment maybe you do morning
something in afternoon something else I
just have a really hard time switching
tasks and so instead of trying to force
myself to switch tasks I designed my
schedule so that I don't have to I think
that's the biggest win that you have as
an entrepreneur you set the rules for
yourself you know yes you have to
provide value to your customers if you
want to make a business happen but you
get the pick you get the pick what your
schedule looks like
and so design around your personality I
think it's super important uh Julie who
is your role model who is my role model
I have a lot of role models I think the
most important of my parents are in the
wall behind me they taught me how to be
a human being my value system comes from
them believe comes from them and they're
my greatest role models of all time they
didn't teach you much about
entrepreneurship apart from you know
bringing yourself to the business and
then from there I think I've learned
from everybody that I've profiled on the
channel like if I haven't learned from
that person we don't put the video up on
the channel and that's been amazing
because I firmly believe that you could
learn something from anybody who's
achieved success it's just something
different and it'll be controversial at
times you know we put up a Donald Trump
video and lots of people are hating on
Donald Trump and he's done a lot of
crazy things but it doesn't mean you
can't learn something from him to help
you be better right if you watch the ten
rules that I put up you could learn from
those even if you don't agree with 99%
of everything else that he's done
you know Steve Jobs I use an example
because I like how he's visionary and
seniors were singularly focused is he a
great parent a great husband that's not
who I want to learn from to raise my son
right and so the idea is not to be any
of these
people to take bits from them take the
part that serves you ignore the rest to
allow you to be the best version of you
I don't want to be the next Steve Jobs I
want to be the best step in Carmichael
possible and so I'm gonna learn
something from him I'm gonna pull a lot
from my parents but I'm not gonna be
exactly like them
I'm gonna pull cell from Donald Trump
I'm gonna pull something from Oprah
Winfrey the parts that resonate with me
I'm gonna go in on that to help me be my
best self and so I think most people are
too close-minded in who they will learn
from and if you can force yourself to
learn from the people who you don't
immediately agree with to find some
point that you can learn from them I
think it can really really serve you
what do we got our Aryan Evan I'm a teen
we got a lot of teenagers today I like
it do you recommend me to take some time
off to discover my passion or should I
go with the mainstream and discover my
calling in the process itself both you
don't need to take time off to pursue
your passion you don't need to take time
off to discover yourself do it like you
think your time is so busy right now
wait till you have kids wait till you
have a marriage you know there's a lot
that's coming at you right this is just
the warmup what you deal with right now
is just the warmup you are capable of
doing both I would before this is this
is the same question to me as do I need
to sleep less right do I need to cut two
hours out of my sleep before abandoning
something before giving up on sleep
before before quitting on school because
you don't have enough time on it where
you're using your time because I bet you
if I stacked up what I do in four hours
and what you're doing in four hours
there'd be a world of difference so make
every minute count before worrying about
leaving school or giving up sleep make
it doesn't matter how much you sleep
right like you're worried about eight
hours versus seven hours how about the
16 that you're awake however many hours
you're at school or doing whatever
you're doing
there's still time outside that you are
not maximizing that you are coasting on
so
use that time first if you have a job
you have evenings you could find your
side hustle in your evenings lots of
people have what's your Excuse I think
too many people blame that they don't
have enough time to do something
we're in reality they're just wasting
tons of time every single day audit your
schedule and say did I make the most of
the time that I have today 99 times out
of 100 it's gonna be no so fix that
first do the thing that you want to do
unwind time now I'm a doctor in England
trying to build a well-being business
tips are grow an audience around this so
be figuring out one your your one word
like what are you staying for what's the
most important core value that you have
and then how can you bring that in a
unique way to your like what's your
philosophy what's your approach how can
you provide value so you're a doctor you
want to promote well-being great like
every doctor wants to promote well-being
why do you become a doctor if you don't
want to help people get well now your
method may be different maybe you're
taking a nutritional approach or an
Exercise approach or a medication
approach or anti medication approach
like what's so different about what
you're going to bring and that's the key
there is you know people look at markets
and they say well there's it's it's too
late to get into that market it's
flooded there's so much competition on
market to start a YouTube channel
there's so many youtubers out there
every market is competitive every market
is competitive and there is always room
for quality at the top there is always
room for quality always so what's the
most quality that you can bring if
you're a doctor what is your unique
approach and then how can you use that
to help people right that's what you
need to figure out and then start
creating content around it whether it's
making videos or those doing interviews
with press releases website like this
law the tactics can change and can all
fit around your personality you know
don't go make YouTube videos if you hate
being on camera and it freaks you out
and you never want to make videos right
like there's a lot of other ways that
you can win but the most important thing
is figuring out your
important core value and then what's so
different about your approach that
people can get on board with next deep
the pion I'm 17 Wow we got the teenagers
I love it I I so wish I had this when I
was 17 man to real the you guys are so
fortunate I hope you really lean in on
the gratitude because you're so
fortunate to have opportunities like
this I'm 17 I want to become an
entrepreneur to the field of science
please give me some advice or tips just
explore if you want to be an
entrepreneur and you're curious about
science I'd be trying to find a way to
merge those two so my first company I
was 19 was a biotech software company
and I didn't care about science it was
my worst subject I dropped it as soon as
I could
I wanted to run away from science as
quickly as possible because I hated it
and then here I was being the owner of a
biotech software company because two
people had started the business when I
was in university and I connected with
them and they asked me to join as an
owner and I felt like I would regret it
if I didn't say yes and so it's just
keeping your ears open for opportunities
and doing a lot of small wins a lot of
small trials and seeing where it goes I
love trying things on a small scale and
then see just see what happens see where
it goes
too often we build up these big ideas in
our heads right like it has to has to be
like this it has to be the perfect plan
you can't plan it perfectly you will
never plan it perfectly sitting there in
your room on your computer you will
never have the perfect plan it does not
exist it will never happen so stop
trying to just plan plan plan plan plan
it perfectly and go and do something on
a small scale and just see what happens
so you want to merge science with
entrepreneurship fantastic tons of
people have done it read their stories
get involved what idea do you have that
you want to bring out into the world do
you want to be the scientist you want to
be the entrepreneur do you want to be
both who are the people that you want to
surround yourself with go to meetups
sort of happening go to entrepreneur
confidence that are happening in your
city like you don't have to travel
around the world to do this tuning the
hangouts ask questions get involved in
communities
and see what jives with you right like
if you're listening to this and you love
this message and say yes I agree
great subscribe to the channel start
watching more content and be part of the
community and you'll find people who are
like-minded if you're listening to this
and you say this is a stupidest thing
ever
I hate Evan great stop watching right
now I can go find somebody else right
but like keep going and doing something
about it
that's the point you have to take action
and then you'll find the people and
you'll find the idea and when you get
the idea start building some kind of
small momentum build the prototype get
it out of your head
build the prototype see people like it
continue to tweak improve as long as
you're still loving the process and
enjoying it then you're gonna win you
got to do something about it
Carice evan i would like to get your
opinion on budgeting for let's scroll
down budgeting for Facebook Ads I was
told that I didn't have two grand to
spend to not even bother would you agree
um you can get started on a smaller
scale it depends on how specific your
market is so as an example if you're
selling the the advantage of a Facebook
campaign is you can get really deep on
specific people to target so for Toronto
dance salsa one of my businesses if I
wanted to target teachers who loved
Grey's Anatomy who lived within a 25
mile radius of my studio I could do that
right so now this is it does it matter
my targeting teachers do I care about
Grey's Anatomy does the location matter
so much the more specific you want to
get the the more it's gonna cost you
right where if you run a general
campaign to anybody it's gonna cost you
a lot less per click but is that person
meaningful to you or not and so that's
what I would need to try to figure out
for your business if you can clearly
identify your target audience you can
clearly know your target audience to say
this is the exact person who's gonna buy
for me here's what they look like here's
their habits here's their marital status
here's where they live you can really
figure that out
then Facebook is going to be the
cheapest way to be able to
reach those people from an advertising
perspective if you're at the point
though where you you know you can't come
up with 2k whether that's the limit
whether one key is the limit like I hate
spending money till I'm making money and
so if I don't have money then I'm
hustling you know I would be if my
audience is that teachers who love
Grey's Anatomy I'd be trying to find
meetup groups I'd be trying to find the
influencers and get to know them and
find ways to go to work together this if
you don't have the money that's okay you
can go off and invest your hustle into
something to see to see how to get
results and often it's better like if
you look at advertising look at a look
at a look at somebody's Facebook feed
what do you pay more attention to look
at your own Facebook feed do you pay
more attention to the ads that are
coming in or do you pay more attention
to what your friends are saying right
the stupid question right like you're on
Facebook to be with your friends and to
learn what's going on not to check out
ads and so if you reverse engineer that
and think okay how can I get more people
to talk about me like who are the people
who if they shared this with mock with
their friends would be significant for
my business and then go out and make
contact with those people and get to
know them and be part of the community
and provide them value and let them know
what you're up to and find some way to
work together I think you'll get more
results out of that and trying to do a
Facebook campaign to be honest
advertising helps you go faster
advertising is like extra gasoline on
the fire but it's very rarely the spark
/ zo Evan how can I start how can I
start maintain my competitive spirit
figure out what inspires you man figure
out what gets you fired up do you do you
like competing does it you need to have
an enemy to have that competitive spirit
do you need to have a big mission a big
goal to get you fired up and ready to go
you just have to break down I would
break down like for any of these things
guys how do I we're talking about habits
how do I keep
is happening right this positive habit
whether its confidence whether its
passion in the work whether its
competitive spirit how do I keep this
thing going
figure at the time that you felt it is
you have multiple times like you've
never been competitive if you grow at
that time and then dissect what happened
and then find a way to bring that to
your daily routine that's it figure that
out it might be reading the book I might
be listening to a podcast I might be
watching a video it might be having a
conversation you might be doing a
workout there's lots of things I might
be doing prayer might be meditation you
might be throwing your cat in the air
three times like doesn't matter whatever
the thing is it gets you feeling that
feeling that you want reverse-engineer
when it has happened because it has and
then figure out a way to do that every
single day that's where the life that
you want starts to come out if you did
that every single day your life will
massively change if you were bold every
single day your life will massively
change it will you can't help it if you
wake up feeling bold and not wake up
right away like wake up like yeah I'm
bullet right you wake up and then you do
the thing that makes you feel bold and
then you have an entire day of boldness
ahead of you your life will change you
can't help it what else the Josh speaks
welcome aboard man the Josh speaks we've
done two collabs go check out his
channel all the teenagers here -
especially go check out josh's channel -
got a lot of great tips
hey Evan do you have any tips for how to
get involved in school communities and
in the classroom mainly with public
speaking or developing content for the
classroom I have a lot of teachers using
my content in the classroom but I
haven't made it a specific goal or
specific ask my first step is now on my
website at the bottom of every page
there's a call for teachers if you are a
teacher I want to work with you and in
general I think there's two ways to
approach these kinds of things sales and
marketing sales is you going out
and trying to drum up support it's
trying to call on people it's trying to
make connections it's trying to build a
list and get in touch with people it
works I don't think it's as effective
maybe maybe it's because I'm not a big
fan of that approach but I don't think
it's as effective as marketing because I
think there's a lot of wasted effort in
that you're trying to build a
relationship a lot of them won't happen
and so that time is yes you've maybe
learn some skills and how to make calls
but it's a lot of waste of time where
marketing is the approach of I'm making
content that I think people will care
about so all of the stuff that I get
incoming from teachers from brand deals
from public speaking all that stuff
comes because of my youtube channel if I
wanted to put a more focus on teachers
what I would do is at the end of all my
videos say I would love to make a
curriculum and get into classrooms guys
it's my number one goal please help me
out here's my email let me know if I put
that at the end of every video that I
put out I would get a ton of teachers
I'd be able to create the curriculum I'd
be speaking across the country going in
the classrooms it's not it's not my
number one priority but I put on my
website and so I would much more lean in
on the marketing side where especially
someone like you Josh who has an
audience who has hundreds of thousand
subscribers the people who are already
part of your community I would be
looking at how can I get them to help me
instead of me going out and trying to
meet new people the people who are
already in my community the people who
already love what I'm all about
I'll be trying to rally them to a
specific cause whether it's a standalone
video or whether it's an ongoing thing
at the end of your videos asking what
you want the harder you are on it the
more frequently you bring up the message
then the more people going to write or a
rally around you to support the cause
that's what I got thank you guys for the
questions is crazy how quickly an hour
flies by for those of you watching if
you have suggestions for my camera
coloring and all that stuff leave it in
the comments after this video is
published because the live stuff
disappears I appreciate the support guys
I will keep my commitment to try to do
every Thursday with you either AMA or
have a guest on I got a bounce I have
some interviews coming up I hope
whatever you're doing today that you
really make a count like take the energy
from this and pour it into your business
to go do something special today like
the work you're doing today whatever
you're doing today you're gonna show
your grandkids the work you're doing
today you are going to show your
grandkids play at that level for the
rest of the day and the rest of the week
and then next week let's start with the
rest of the day thank you guys for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love guys I'll see you soon